their prescription I want to see who you
were talking to I wanted to look at her
[Laughter]
[Music]
you were intriguing across the room you
talking to me too as well yeah as well
but I can see you you can very close the
way I have such an image of you burnt in
my brain do you know I'm on the Rich
Eisen app every day when you don't do a
show I check to see if there's something
I missed
I love it you know what and I appreciate
you saying that
um because I love everything that you do
as well so it's a mutual admiration
society again I will share this every
now and then I will get a text from you
out of the blue saying I love you man
and I'm like well what brought that on
and it's just whatever you I love your
wife I know your children I love you and
let me just say something I might take
my miles Garrett take okay well if you
were a little concerned one of what's
the loose cannon gonna say ya know I
have two words for you yes Jackie
Robinson Jackie Robinson was called that
name many many many times did he pick up
the bat and go after people no he did
not
okay Jackie Robinson busted open the
doors for everybody in every situation
all human beings are better because of
Jackie Robinson
so I'm saying that's not an excuse to
slam a man with a helmet all right move
on Oh Jeff Garlin everybody here on the
Rich Eisen show discussed that more with
Chris Brockman's news update yes do that
with Brockman later after I've gone to
wear red sweatpants big move but you
know some people fly in a plane yes and
they dress like pigs yes I unfortunately
I have a tiny sum
like a 1950's college-football doesn't
do travel with a coat and tie quite
often here's my situation at home right
yes I have a lovely woman who comes once
a week to does my wash and I use dry
cleaners - my assistant
fractured her foot yes and therefore
there's no truck I'm wearing the last of
it
I do have underwear on a pair of brand
new boxers yes from the good people of
son Spelling in England they're really
top-quality boxers yes yes all stuff
that came in the mail this morning come
on like you these are from roots of
fight they're the Mike Mike Tyson sweat
pants got those yes and these champion
spark this is actually been in my drawer
for a while never worn it this is the
first time is this time it's your first
all new stuff new underwear new socks
it's all new it's the last of what I
have I have nothing that's clean that's
old and I would not come on your show in
old clothes is what is this is this a
throwback to is that the Brad Pitt shirt
firm once upon a time in spark plug
shirt that black Brad Pitt
he did wear one like this in once upon a
time in Hollywood and don't think that I
didn't think that was a good look I take
my shirt off work on the roof neighbor
looks at me we exchange nods yes my
neighbors an elderly man and it's good
work it's good work I do on the roof and
I beat up personally once you know what
there's no there's no similarities
that's when the divergence I happen to
know where you're going you're going to
Chicago part of Chicago I'm going to do
press for my special yes like special it
can be named right now as a matter of
fact if you're watching right now turn
this off
and start streaming me really we're
talking about Rich Eisen I guess it's
just not any ordinary show thank you
it's Rich Eisen stay here you don't want
to miss it if you care people do okay
I know people care but I need to see you
the best you're going to Chicago to
Chicago going to see the Bears yes sir
what's the answer
Bears fan nobody expected the Giants to
do anything so they stink and they're
doing what they're supposed to do the
Bears were supposed to be good and
they're not even mediocre okay who do
you point the Jeff Garlin finger or
blame towards on that front well I'll
know I'll end up meeting him and he'll
be a nice guy or whatever but the coach
the coach yeah I don't blame trubotsky
Drew Pinsky skill set is as good as
people have won who have won Super Bowls
I'm sorry you either have a great
quarterback or a quarterback that can do
what you need him to do and if he's not
doesn't have that great skill set yes
then you put a playbook together that
works on the strengths and what the
quarterback can do that is not happening
we have an exciting young running back
and David Montgomery what's happening
with him nothing Tarricone a dynamite I
mean just amazing what's happening with
him nothing that defense has suffered at
the hands of how bad that offenses so
it's the play caller it's not the play
execution that's right the PlayBook is
ridiculous I put my hand in my head like
this all game every either I'm there or
I'm watching on TV I've not missed a
minute and it is nothing but but why
would it work last year and now suddenly
not this year you know what I mean like
so that's the point is you know Troy's
Jordan Howard
point is yeah yeah Jordan Howard why
would they check I mean he's fine Bobby
why would they sign for a lot of money
blame the GM - I am in the coach get rid
of them get rid of them
yeah the defensive coordinator should be
the new head coach you like Chuck Pagano
oh love Chuck Pagano Chuck Pagano is a
great one it took a lot to get him out
in Baltimore right now Indianapolis
right yeah because you know he was
against way he's a great coach that's
our coach that's our coach let's make
the move now get rid of the GM
Brockman's new bear's GM would you
accept that role Chris what's the first
move he would make that's the Paris
general man Wow great question I'd sign
Tom Brady right no it's the same crappy
play calling so what does it matter
unless it's a new coach there's somebody
else that's interesting a quarterback
that's gonna be available Cam Newton Cam
Newton would you take him of course I
would but you loved your Biscay I don't
love Drew Pinsky I said he's good enough
and I'm not blaming him I'm not at all
right I am blaming the coach in the GM
they make weird moves
so you're but you'd still despite all
this yes you're getting on an airplane
I'm a Bears fan and you're going to the
producer of the gulper it's all birds
yes okay and excellent gentlemen yes and
I am getting on a plane to go see the
Bears because I love the Bears and I
have magical seats if you do this it's
the 50 great right behind the bench if
you didn't have your NFL access yes I
take you to judge I would still go to
guess those to the show how many times
many many times I guest-hosted I know
you
but you're busy it's the same reason
Leno never had any one guest host you're
scared that I'm gonna be that much
better than umbers you have not seen yet
tell him where the last guest host of
this program was broadly yes her skill
set damn impressive you know so ever
concerned about having somebody sitting
in this she does replace you which would
be hilarious but I know you
yeah just like me that even if we made a
nickel for being a stand-up are you
doing this we'd still do it because it's
what we do and we're blessed because we
do what we love I would love for you to
do but you're Jeff you're you got a lot
going on playing I'm playing with you
I'm too successful
I mean seriously you're showing up at a
champion t-shirt you got your your
latest of Mike Tyson where you're going
on a plane to Chicago to watch your four
and seven bears yeah that's right boy to
go to so they are they are much more of
an embarrassment than the Giants and
they're too like Hall of Fame yeah
teams I mean the Bears and the Giants
are what football is all about right you
know I gave you one extra lost you four
and six to trying to vote for instance
if you lose to the Giants there is no if
come on no we'll probably beat the
Joshua the point being is yeah what does
that mean if you beat the Giants it's
like beating the Jets that's okay Jeff
Garlin you're on a richer by the way
yeah if it wasn't for Joe Namath the
Jets would have no history
Joe Namath literally is the Jets the
Jets are the prediction that Super Bowl
it was like we view bank it is the Jets
since then by the way I was a big
Richard Todd fan like Richard does so
was I um
and here's the issue I have with what
you just said tell me
I am retort las' you're my party I'm
retort las' I am NOT I know it I know I
know
respond to what you said with a yeah but
okay I cannot see almost appear to me
love the Jets you and Larry David now
you have the jet you spell the little
beans on Good Morning football that the
Jets are involved integrally in a Curb
Your Enthusiasm yes there's a big
there's a few people yes who seek herbs
before they air Larry likes feedback
you're one of them beyond history I will
just say this about the episode is that
when it was made that the upcoming jet
season had yet to be played yeah it was
just an assumption so and there was some
concern that if the Jets performed in a
certain way it might undercut the spirit
of the episode yes and we're in the
clear football fan I love football yes
it is exciting when the Jets or the
Giants are play great
I think it's fancy New York is so
important that's why the Knicks are the
saddest story I think in all of sports
the Knicks are the saddest thing there
is well at least I can pour myself into
something which is what
one of the things I want hit with you
when we come back after we take a break
Chicago this this new this new bromance
in the NBA that appears to be blossoming
right before our very eyes
Jeff Garlin and Steve Ballmer oh the
owner of the Los Angeles Clippers I need
to hit on that with you too do we also
have a start bench cut for you because
we love the sharp edge [ __ ] okay we got
that and then we'll send you to the Los
Angeles International to head off to
Chicago Chicago and then we'll get
Christmas news update once he leaves
that's how we're gonna Emma will also
get some more of the phone calls people
then hold and I will be guest hosting
before the year 2020 is over I would
love that I'd love to say 219 but you
won't let me you're scared
I am absolutely inviting you to do it
but that's okay so scared it's okay Jeff
Garlin keep the same insignia of you
running if we cook in the Jeff Garlin
just Chris Brockman's news update phone
calls still to come but when we come
back more with Jeff Garlin you can check
out Jeff Garlin our man in Chicago
available on Netflix right now but only
do it once see leaves seventh season of
Goldberg's on ABC Wednesday by Alec Barr
now who's who's a Bears fan who's also
going to the game I wanted to give him
Chris the fourth who's the fourth three
I have three season tickets that's it
yeah three that's an odd number to go
back with Jeff Garlin in a moment we're
back on the Rich Eisen sure are so bad
all right
Jeff Garlin celebrating his 37th year of
stand up with Jeff Garlin our man in
Chicago available on Netflix out is 37 a
special year or no no what happened was
I was on site the night before I was
filming it occurred to me that the next
night when I was actually filming was my
37th anniversary exactly where and where
was your first ever that was in Florida
at the comic strip on federal highway in
Fort Lauderdale how many people were in
that establishment I actually word got
out okay amongst people who knew me cuz
okay you packed the house it was a
funniest kid I didn't pack it they all
showed up okay
the past auditions
boom 20 years old started my career so
you were draw at age 20 is what you're
saying momentarily the next weekend I'm
forgetting when it came I ran high all
right so what's with you and Steve
Bomberman
all right how many games has he taken
you to I bet a clipper fan for well spit
was my LA team yes okay but I was always
a Bulls fan I got so frustrated with the
Bulls I started watching more Clippers
games and that team last year I fell in
love was a delightful team they over
achieved I love them and my three
favorites are still on
montrezl harrell and Patrick Beverley
were my three favorites and so we didn't
have to get rid of them to make things
happen
so I even have goosebumps right now I
just love that team so last year I go
with Doug Robinson yeah the the 76ers
invited me to a game and I'm not gonna
be a Sixers fan no matter what happens
and so I'm walking around and I see
Steve Ballmer go hey we had a
conversation we hit it off he invited me
to a game and after being at a game and
also hanging with Jerry West and
halftime during the game who told me
really interesting things that have been
proven true that I told you and someone
brought it up with him and he denied it
but it's been proven true he was
concerned about a certain first-round
draft picks knee and he said that John
Moran would be amazing this is what the
genius of all time in basketball sit so
I'm hanging with him he also talked
about Amazon not the Amazon Amazon you
know it was fascinating loved it it was
still I play out I'm like I'm all-in I'm
on I bought season tickets yes
before the acquiring of kawaii and so
what is it like sitting next to Palmer
and again it's fantastic but he's easy
constant constantly he is focused but
yet he laughs at all my jokes but he has
completely
he yells defense yes and then we just
last week completely by accident we're
on The Daily Show together no kidding we
were both we're both laughing I walk in
the dress c'mon what's going on but he's
I would have to say he is my pal no
doubt about it
so you crossed over from acquaintances
to friends we text each other and I love
the dude he is every dream that you want
for a sports owner so passionate yet
let's the people do their giant absurdly
wealthy so you know the depth he's the
wealthiest owner in all of sports
basketball right oh [ __ ] what does he
chit chat during the owner he wants no
chit chat cuz he's focused on about
everything he loves the Pirates of the
Caribbean movies to bring up you like
two or three better out Force Ones the
best but two or three after they know
he's a big Johnny Depp guy
no no he's he's just he's fantastic he
talks about everything he's the best huh
yeah that's amazing yeah it is by the
way it's amazing it's a dream I am
signed to the Clippers yeah as long as
Steve Ballmer or someone he loves owns
that which means forever pre-much fan
yeah of course I say of course because
people who are really intelligent and
there you are sitting next to him look
at you BFFs what's what that's an
odd-looking clap though I gotta be
honest with you in the middle of the
game there's nothing at stake he does
that all game well for me
I wait like last night's game versus
Altec yeah you should as I was there
yeah and you you I would have I was
doing somersaults it was it was insane
Brockman was there last night too that
was a good game amazing
amazing Jane bird late November we're
talking about patrick beverley in the
waves which please they should but the
block actually blocks were you sitting
by bomber last night no in front of me
oh and by the way i'm all out on the
balls instead of like the bulls are my
second favorite team they're gone you're
clipper now if Michael Jordan's not
playing for the balls I'm done yeah he's
not playing for the Pippen horse grant
that's Mike and also Chet Walker Bob
love I love the shirt I mean that's your
Tom boerwinkle I love the balls he'll
cut right broke my heart but I still am
all-in on Blackhawks Bears and Cup okay
but the Clippers are your adopted team
well yeah you know it's funny you know
Chris Brock went with Jeff Garlin you're
on the rich as a joke you know Brockman
you came in years ago and you said to me
Brockman is dating someone who is
awesome not up there with your wife
right guys that I appreciate that are
you were they Sarah Tiana is now with
child because I did David Spade show
that's how desperate I've become but no
she's a writer on that show and I see
that belly and I I'm like are you
kidding me I was so happy I am so happy
for them they are gonna have a great
child and be great parents and I'm gonna
give him a really nice gift I gained oh
I know I gave him advice that you gave
me when we were suzanne and i first had
our first is that do you know about
being present right and that even when
you are sitting with your kid watching
one of their terrible shows or movies or
whatever you're not watching the show
you're watching a kid a child yeah
because it goes so fast it goes so fast
and my kids would watch the you know the
my sipping kid shows and i just stared
at them I didn't look at frenita mouth
though you're like even if they say
you're freaking me out just don't care
never said that because you know I would
turn away they're not smart enough to
catch thee you know and yeah it was just
you know my boys are 19 to 23 still kiss
him all the time love them can't get
enough of them still stare at them
my son Duke went with me to the game
last night oh you think I didn't stare
at him at the game during the game oh
yes I did nineteen years old I was there
have you ever gotten confused and stared
at Steve Ballmer by accident then no but
Steve stares at me all right before we
send you to Los Angeles International
Airport
let's do a stark bench cut okay start
bench cut we're gonna give you again for
those who are just joining us here on
the Rich Eisen show for whatever reason
you have to choose one to start one to
bench one to cut we've got three choices
yes first up the Chicago Bears 2020
starting quarterback here your choices
you must start one bench one in cut one
Cam Newton Phillip Ridge of rivers and
your current quarterback Mitchell true
Biscay started ng start Cam Newton I
bench Mitch strabinsky and I cut Phillip
Rivers huh really
Phillip Rivers comes available this
offseason
no really no one you know you see in
sports you see age come in when it comes
in the moment we're at the pile of the
Rivers has been an excellent quarterback
but the way he's playing is not because
of he's got a bit of an offensive line
problem but still it's a big bowl of
he's Phillip Rivers yeah so my
prediction is is that you're gonna run
it back with your coach and quarterback
they're gonna run it back 2020 will be
negative coach and the trooper skis the
quarterback of course that's the way
it's gonna go
if they got rid of the coach and or the
quarterback the GM is going oh I stink
exactly takes forever to get rid of
somebody they're not getting rid of the
GM no it's all the same next I think
they're gonna run it back yeah and guess
what
I'll still be there okay very good next
one up you know
them you know there's the latest story
about the Houston Astros and it's okay
in most egregious form of cheating in
baseball yeah must start one bench one
cut one using cameras and signals to
steal signs using corked bats
performance-enhancing drugs what's the
worst one and then the one you cut is
one like ah it's no big deal okay the
worst one while using cameras did you
say cameras and signals to steal sign
yes signals I'm not worried about but
cameras I think takes it looks like if a
player gets the second base yeah you
know fair game so I would say with using
cameras the second one corked bats by
the way that's a big cork bed okay so I
start cork bat okay because right away
that is huge cheating I anytime you need
a drill to power tools bench I bench
watching more cameras cameras and I cut
performance-enhancing drugs you know I
am not throw steroids all that but a lot
of guys use steroids so it kept them
going you take someone like Barry Bonds
who is a ridiculous baseball player give
him a chance to get stronger and and
every day have his energy he's gonna
tear apart the universe so I cut that
one have you ever used it
performance-enhancing drug yourself Jeff
from a wiener got it next one here we go
next one everybody start beds cut best
place to watch a Cubs home game
bleachers rooftop bar across the street
in a luxury box next to Tom rickets okay
you start a luxury box next to Tom
rickets okay which I've never done I
have sat at the game next to Tom rickets
summers times but first row okay but I
would say luxury box cuz you're right
there bleachers number two and then
rooftop I did that once
oh is that a waste of time what do you
mean oh it's lame now you know I used to
live there with Conan and before they
change the thing and built this one
building from my back porch when I lived
there with Conan I could see down the
third base line the home plate and it
was so fun in a second for those who may
not know you lived with Conan O'Brien
yes in one on Sheffield or Kenmore okay
right by show of Sheffield okay and they
you know added that the apartment who I
got the apartment from was dan
Castellaneta you know how versus Homer
since and then I was friends with Dan
from second city so that wasn't even
part of it because Conan came in after I
already lived there but from my back
porch right could see into Wrigley died
watch Andre Dawson bat-like down the
third-base line from left feel it was
Conan O'Brien like his a roommate it was
a delightful roommate I was the bad
roommate for example I had
air-conditioning in my room I would go
in and shut the door and not invite him
in which was so hot in the summertime
huh and the poor guy he actually threw
away his food tongue when he moved out
because it was just so sick away his
futon it was not he was not proclaim
about not reclaim a ball unless you like
that sort of stuff
last one for you yes this is gonna be a
good one if we go out with a bang if you
will start then Scott Jeff Garlin yes
most suggestive sports phrase for this
generation load management beating the
shift' tanking okay well I'm gonna go
reverse on this okay sure
beating the shift is cut lettin you know
think that he's involved a bit the
lexicon he's not okay so what are the
other two load management and tanking
okay tanking I would bench okay load
management
dear God man that works on so many
levels I mean and I use my before you
have seen drugs it doesn't help with my
load management but I gotta say I
believe fully in load management as
as a Clippers fan
I believe in Lotus I'm sure you do so
load management is a big one for me I
just it's we talked about it the other
day whoever came up with the phrase you
know we need to come up with a way to
make it sound official that we're just
resting our players and it sounds
something serious let's call it load
management without actually having to
describe what the load is that is being
managed right you know so it works on a
lot of levels I say it's probably some
general manager somebody and then it was
a broadcaster who repeated it and then
it gets used and then used it's always
broadcasters who it's like the term my
bad I hate it right and my opinion is it
started with somebody who worked with
the mentally challenged and if he is
that something that just sounds like I'm
mentally challenged person would say
right and they were out playing
basketball and then they they made it a
foul and someone said something oh my
bad sometimes what's that oh I must have
heard it at work though Jeff Garlin
everybody before I let you go yeah we
also there's another phrase that's out
there that it does sound like something
out of curb well which is as long as you
say with all due respect you could say
anything disrespectful you know I simply
want after that if you do that you're
being rude here's the way you do it okay
okay if I were to say with all due
respect I would add you shouldn't and
then explain what it is you're doing yes
okay which is a word of advice but I
think that the proper way to say it yes
and when people use it is this with all
due respect and obviously I'm not
showing you an e I'm have none for you
and then you make the statement so
there's two versions yes one with all
due respect you're my friend but I think
this right which is thoughtful and I'm
helping you and the other is I'm being
an ass
[Laughter]
you do but when you pick your nose or
whatever that's what I'm saying people
using the phrase with all the respect
feels it makes it feel like they've met
and now have free license today it's not
a free license and they look like a jerk
that's what I'm saying so unless you add
one of those two yes either but I think
for you here's my thoughts right or you
say I have no respect for you I'm saying
this sounds like something if there's a
no you want to put that it's a curb idea
that's what I'm saying 40 explain this
you don't like it listen okay so never
mind about my special people coming up
and asking me what's Larry David really
like and when people want to do a
picture whatever it's a kind thoughtful
thing I'm honored what I don't have time
for is people coming up with their curb
ideas based on their risk their lives
thing happened to me it's a great curb
ID and I go listen no one has ever told
me an idea yes I've then said that's
brilliant
let me tell no this one will be then
they'll tell me and I'll have to tell
them see why did you do it because
here's the point that people don't know
right I'm an executive producer on Curb
Your Enthusiasm
I'm involved I'm involved with
creatively show I in the history of the
show have never told Larry an idea for
the show never once never once I've
never walked up to one and by the way I
got a lot of them I write my own stuff
I've never gone up to one hey man how
about this or this happened to me nope
ah so if I producer a creative producer
don't please come up and tell me you
like the show or I'll say hello to you
I'm wind everybody you know you could
say well with all due respect say you're
bill Schwartz on the street Phil Schwarz
on the street hey I've got this great
idea for curveball due respect it I
don't know you so I have no respect for
you
phrase with all due respect from
actually having to be obvious that
you're gonna be disrespectful it is an
obvious statement with all due respect
is obvious that you have no respect you
have no respect so add that with all due
respect and let them know what level
it's at respect for you so if I said
with all due respect and I have a lot of
respect for you I really think it would
help you if I'm trying to help you miss
as a person and I'm gentle because I
have great respect for you thank you but
if I don't ever bill Schwartz at the
farmers market I have no respect do you
go far
I saw the farmers market all the time I
loved one that they replaces third and
Fairfax find me there check him out his
farmers market sure dude Fairfax and
also on his Netflix special Jeff Garlin
our man in Chicago yeah available right
now you're gonna be an actual man in
Chicago I could get you to your flight
thanks for coming on the show hey by the
way as always an honor thank you right
back guys say that with all due respect
for more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR live or download the Rich Eisen
show app